it's crucial for leaders today to be
able to communicate effectively if as a
leader you want to influence the
direction of an organization or the
output of your employees and your team
members the best tool in your toolkit as
a leader is effective and clear
communication the first place I begin
when I work with a leader who is trying
to communicate more effectively is to
teach a very simple framework that
allows you to create a strategy before
you ever write or ever speak and the
heart of that strategy is just the word
aim who is my audience what is my intent
and what is my message if a leader can
think through audience intent and
message as they're creating an email or
a tweet or a report or a presentation
and really distill within each of those
three pieces what is it they want to
achieve with the audience that they're
speaking to that's the first place to
become more effective as a leader who
communicates
the more I know about the group of
people that I'm trying to communicate
with what inspires them to action where
do they gather what resources do they
rely on what sources of news do they
read what are their peer groups of
influence the more I understand the
audience
the more I can decide what's the best
vehicle or multiple vehicles that I
might want to use in order to
communicate with them when I'm only
communicating with one person and I'm
doing it interpersonally with just two
people sitting in a room I have the full
benefit of both the verbal in the
nonverbal communication between me and
that other person as a leader I don't
have that freedom where every message I
deliver I can deliver one-on-one so as I
start communicating to a small group of
people a larger group of people a very
large group or a mass audience I have to
also expand the different vehicles that
I might use choosing the vehicle or
vehicles that can be most effective
based on the audience analysis that I've
done
anytime that a leader is standing up in
front of a group of people to deliver a
message there are three aspects to that
communication there's the verbal which
are the actual words that that person
says to the audience if I was to do a
transcript of everything that was said
that's the verbal component of the
communication there's also the vocal
component of the communication how loud
or how soft how much I use pauses for
emphasis or how rapid I deliver to show
a sense of excitement and enthusiasm for
what's coming that's the vocal aspect of
the communication but the third and many
researchers argue the most powerful
aspect of communication is the visual
the nonverbal communication my sense of
gestures eye contact movement even how
I'm dressed and the posture that I use
all is a part of my presence as a leader
in front of a group of people so when
the visual the vocal and the verbal all
come together effectively then a leader
is able to have a sense of executive
presence as they deliver a presentation
share a story or have a conversation
with the teams that they're leading
you